[Music]
mack
is with us mac is in raleigh north
carolina i'm mac
welcome to the ramsey show hey how's it
going dave
better than i deserve what's up all
right so
i'm going into my junior year of college
at app state university
and i have this money that i've been
making
like over the summer um for doordash i
have like roughly three to four thousand
dollars just kind of sitting in my bank
account
um i'm just sort of curious like where
to go
um because i'm gonna be coming into
student loan debt
in about two years here i'm not quite
sure
like what to do if i should put it in an
iron
you're in there coming into student loan
debt you mean you've got student loan
debt that'll be due
after you graduate it's yeah
i mean well i'll start my payments like
in
yeah so how much student loan debt do
you have
um it'll be 22 000 okay
and are you uh are you still using
student loan debt for your junior and
senior year
yes okay like all together it'll be 22.
yeah how much is it now
uh 10. okay so what would happen if you
decided i'm gonna make the other 12
instead of going into debt
you got three good right
how about taking out no more student
loans
that's an option yeah bust your butt and
pay cash for the rest of it
gotcha and then and then i'm
through baby step two and then just
start well you still got the 10 000
laying there that you've already taken
out right but we're just going to stop
doing damage as our first goal
and then when you graduate from school
you'll just attack the 10 000 with your
new job
you know that'll be a lot better than
any college job
hopefully and what are you studying
um i'm studying cedar performance and
then i have a double major in
business marketing okay so what is your
plan for your career
um i went to this uh place in new york
city called
theater theatrical rights worldwide and
they offered me a job out of college but
i kind of got to look into that and
salary wise so i'd be um
marketing and selling shows for a
company
cool sounds like you get to use
everything you've learned
yeah that would be neat okay cool
yeah and you don't know what it pays and
it's a ways out so you've got to button
that thing up between now and then but
in the meantime you've got to finish up
your junior and your senior year and you
got to pay cash in your 9 000
short to do that that's right
and so you can do that though because
you found work you got you
you're rolling you see anything ken i i
think dave's absolutely right
i think you're working really hard and
if you made three to four thousand this
summer
uh you know you keep doing that you've
got your 12 grand right there and you're
cashflowing your way through college so
yeah i'd work
really really hard i would not take any
more student loans you don't need it
you've got the ability to do it so just
stay the course here
no more student loan debt and you're
you're gold
i i love this i would look into the new
york thing i want you to be more clear
on what that looks like
you know you've been offered you need to
know right off the top of your head
insulin okay this is what it's going to
cost
to live there and run those numbers on
that before you decide to take that new
york job yeah
but i mean really we're talking about
this is june
so yeah if if the junior year is this
fall
it's two years to come up with uh
uh nine thousand dollars that's that's
only about four hundred dollars a month
that's exactly right i worked full-time
in college i did too
when i said full-time i mean 40 hours
plus i mean i was busting it on the
weekends really hard
you know what much of a week in life but
it worked yeah
it got me through it